oh my god
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by sam smith
their four-time grammy award winner
multiple guinness world records and oh
yeah an academy award on the shelf as
well for good measure
the third studio album love goes is set
to release on october 30th
tomorrow actually let's celebrate with
some wings sam smith welcome to the show
amazing thank you for having me how are
you around spicy food because with our
british guests it is a little bit hit or
miss right yeah
no it is all these sauces by my side
right now
are just scaring me i hope i'm gonna
survive this
[Music]
i'm gonna go for i'm just gonna pull
like quite a lot wow
is that too much don't don't scare me
this early on i think you're okay
but as we inch up
that's nice that's really really nice
i'm bummed we're not shooting this one
in the pub sam i heard you wanted to
shoot in the pub
i don't know the pub is my favorite
place in the whole world
i wish you i wish you were here in
london that i could take you out
same with me because my whole thing with
this like when i visit
london my favorite thing is to go for a
cheeky beer that's my favorite
part of sort of london day-to-day life
how would you describe
british pub culture to someone who's
never experienced it i don't know but
to be honest pubs here are there's these
beautiful places
where you you have quiz nights i have
quiz nights in my local pubs all around
where i live
and um i come it's the best place for a
date
it's this it's just low-key great
lighting a lot of the time
soulful people it's always wonderful
seeing the you know the old guy in the
corner who's there every single night
the bougie pub is definitely more
regular in london right now
you've got to really hum for the old
school ones it's part of our history i
guess
what does it mean to have a proper knees
up uh
proper knees up for me would be
it would be a sunday and it would be a
roast we'd have a roast
at a pub and then we'd day drink
and then for me on a sunday night in
london
in a place called vauxhall there's this
place called horsemeat disco
so i drink throughout the day and then
you go and dance to disco music until
3am
and then ruin your monday basically so
that's my idea for me
[Music]
i like the color of this one oh [ __ ] put
too much on the game
oh i like that that's really nice you
dig that one
[Music]
all right so when we had noel gallagher
on the show he talked about how
difficult it is to make relatable music
the second you go from a
singer-songwriter to a full-blown rock
and roll star
are there challenges to writing for
albums like the thrill of it all
love goes that maybe you didn't have
before all the grammy and brit awards
oh about god of course of course i mean
i always
i read a quote once from patty smith and
she said um
nothing that um kills creativity like
fame and money and success and i do i
have to agree you know
when you know people are listening you
know it can definitely affect what you
make a little bit in the studio so you
have to work
really hard to block out the noise
not look left and right [ __ ] that's got
a kick to it
[Music]
oh my god the face on the front that's
gonna be me
these are amazing i'm not gonna lie
these are so good
i've never had but we sent them across
the pond for you sam so uh so you can
keep them
so good hmm
so you're probably known for your style
only second to music and in the how do
you sleep video the outfits can range
from a t-shirt and jeans
to a green suit to heels in a trench
coat
do you see that music video as a
metaphor for your capacious sartorial
tastes
yeah do you know what yeah i mean i love
that video so much i actually
normally when i release anything i don't
really watch it or listen to it
maybe hardly ever again to be honest and
the other night i was at home
and i uh i watched the video for some
reason and
i i love that video and it does yeah it
kind of um
it takes in all my kind of things i love
i'm like a bit of a
shape-shifter to be honest the way i
dress in the way that i
feel every day changes but hills for me
are a bit of a nightmare i've come to
realize because
i'm six too so if i wear hills it's just
i make i make uh short men quite
uncomfortable
i don't want to put too much pressure on
this question because i know that there
are too many to name
so just off the top of your head and
without thinking about it
too much who do you think is the
musician
who had the biggest influence on
changing the way that people dress
kanye west came to my head immediately
and then i'd say
rihanna the album loud i was 17 when
that record came out
and i remember she just started wearing
high street brands loads
and i just remember this whole shift
happening of like oh wow this this those
pop stars wearing what
we can afford and that's amazing and
then it it shifted fashion for me
in a huge way
angry go oh god
oh that that that's got a kick to it
that one wow
oh no this is the before yep
i'm scared i'm scared so on this swing
we're not asking you to give away the
secret recipe but we do obsess about the
anatomy of a hit none money on my mind
you say
could you write a song for me i say i'm
sorry i won't do that happily
what's the difference between a song
that sam smith wants to make
and a song that sam smith's label wants
to make or that sam
smith's fans expect sam smith to make
there's a pressure to have to make songs
that would appeal to
to many people but a song
that i want to make is always going to
be just personally about me and
my experiences and sometimes that isn't
relatable
um but i'm really recently i'm really
learning when
when and not to cross that line um but
there's also weird there's weird ones
like too good at goodbyes my song
i didn't like that song i wasn't even
gonna go on my record
and then my label you know would i
please give it a go
and i gave it a go and even when i
released it i wasn't too keen on it and
then
when i sang it on tour it's now one of
my favorite songs to sing
so it's it's weird sometimes the label
make decisions
that that i end up agreeing with
later on down the line but they've also
had some clangers clanger ideas too
[Music]
my lips are tingling
great do you have a favorite so far
my favorite right now is this one
it's aquinas west indian curry
shaqwanders
shout out shaqwanda and i love the
packaging i'm a sucker for good
packaging
i want to meet shakonda all right sam we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that gram where we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story they
say you should never meet your heroes
but i've heard you say that this is an
exception do you remember the first
face-to-face meeting you ever had with
elton john
yeah first time i met him was he invited
me to his house in london
and i was a new artist and me my manager
went to his house
and we sat and had a cup of tea with him
and we just got on so well and he's been
this wonderful figure who he just calls
me out when i've done a really bad song
he'll call me and tell me
this song is awful sad you need to do
better than that
and he will he called me up on my second
album and he didn't like my second album
title and he's very very honest with me
and i
i never ever thought in my life that i'd
have such a lovely relationship with him
and
guidance from him actually every time it
happens i'm i'm really thankful for it
because
he is the greatest he's the greatest of
all time
[Music]
scorpion oh no this is scary
i want to do loads i don't want to be a
winner
let's do it
jesus christ
you can just taste that heart like the
other ones i feel like have this
this first taste of like oh it's nice
come in
like this inviting kind of this one
straight up hard
so in 2013 japanese scientists at the
tokyo university of the arts discovered
that listening to sad
songs can actually evoke positive
emotions in the brain
do you ever think of your saddest songs
as actually being your happiest songs
yeah weirdly sorry about you like this
is hot
um i uh yeah
yeah um my
they bring they bring me a lot of joy
actually some of my sadly songs
you just using those moments in the
studio as a form of therapy is
incredible
it's always a wonderful feeling to
listen back and also something good
comes out of a bad situation
which to me is a is a wonderful thing
that's one of the best things about
being an
artist is take something painful and
make it wonderful
and hopefully it will help people
oh it's about not being alone right i
think when you're sad you feel
alone in your feelings i'm making music
like that makes you not feel alone
are you struggling because i feel like
you're not struggling
well you know there's nothing that's
going on here that i haven't experienced
before like you this is your first
time so then when you're in uncharted
territory
failing a little bit no
right so you can be like a little
panicked like what's going on here is
this normal and then
the bald guy on the other side of the
zoom seems unbothered
but sam i'm right with you and you're
doing really good you're doing really
good
thank you so much all right are you
ready to move
on here to the next wing i think i am i
think i am
this is the one i was dreading the most
because it's called hellfire
[Music]
oh wow oh
nice really nice
yup every step forward for the rest
of the gauntlet is exponential that's
nice i feel like
i'm gonna wait a minute i mean i feel
like the one before is even
actually no way okay wait
let's kick it in yep
see i'm in this this is the part of the
show where i just say be careful around
your eyes
you know what i mean don't touch your
eyes don't wipe your eyes if you have a
little sweat
i can't save you from from across the
pond you know okay all right all right
wow that kicks in mm-hmm
so you want an oscar for best original
song for doing the theme to the 2015
james bond film spectre and i read that
you actually lobbied for that project
by emailing your agent and in the
subject line just putting double07
were you interested in taking on that
project because you know it's a
soundtrack it's a new challenge or
did you just have an obsession with the
bond films growing up as a kid in
england
for me growing up here it's always been
um such a huge part of our lives and our
culture
and my my dad's brother my uncle terry
he's um he's he was born with brain
damage and and
he's a wonderful wonderful man and he
has
this one obsession throughout his whole
life that's james bond
so i guess it's always been in my mind
since i've been a kid because he
when i say he's obsessed i mean he's
obsessed it's all he talks about
growing up it was it was always this
thing in my mind that was
one of the greatest things that we have
in the uk
we i just thought i'd be a bit cocky and
reach out
and i did it's really hard to talk um
so yeah i am still so grateful
for the opportunity to do that it was a
mad experience though because
with the bond song what i really didn't
realize about that is there is there is
some real fans out there
who are waiting to hear something and
i think no matter who brings out a bomb
song there's always going to be a group
of people going
hate that some of the greatest classic
songs are bond songs
so it's this constant comparison to the
past
the bomb beyond insanity oh my gosh
is that enough do you think yeah that's
that's um i would actually
wipe a little bit of that off i've been
putting double the amount of that
i know in these quarantine episodes we
have no way of
uh no
no this isn't fun now oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
no no no that's really [ __ ]
yep it's almost like we do it on purpose
you know
oh that's horrible oh
[Music]
it's always a moment of the show i feel
like i have to apologize for
i'm sorry i'm sorry
oh
is it still a dream of yours to open up
a flower shop in the english countryside
i actually didn't think it was gonna be
that bad
you're gonna need to wait a sec oh my
god
oh my god
[Music]
i would love to open up
a garden center actually this is
horrible
you you you are so composed
did you really have that i'm right in
here with you
i don't want to panic you but but listen
i can't feel my tongue
sorry i thought that was water and i
think it's tequila
oh my god oh no
that's the worst thing i've ever had in
my mouth and i've had a lot of things in
my mouth
i'm telling you
oh my god my nipples
oh
[Music]
that was really really really hard oh my
god
all right
[Music]
i'm worried about getting on the toilet
tomorrow if i'm honest
yeah listen that's that's so that's a
worthwhile concern
i'm going to be honest with you sir oh
that is horrible it's just horrible
do you think some people actually have
that for the joy of having it
you know it's funny i get that question
every once in a while and i
think we are the only people that are
actually
using this sauce
very rich
[Music]
pepper vibe
[Applause]
[Music]
so with halloween just around the corner
i think it's worthwhile to discuss
you living in a house that you believe
to be haunted by ghosts
have you ever done any research on the
property like does it have a unique
history
yeah so my house is actually like it's
part of an old school
and my um my uh
section of the house because it's split
into different houses um
was probably like where the nuns would
sleep
so there's probably like a freaky nun in
my house
but i feel like it's a nice presence
because whenever i hear her
or feel her around i don't feel too
scared
i think that most people would feel
uneasy about having a roommate that is
an otherworldly
ghost none but you find it kind of
magical and exciting
yeah oh my god if there's if there's
those i mean my mother always
talks about this story
about when i was a baby when i was
younger
and her father passed away she said
she one day you know she walked into her
bedroom
and she said she saw him there at the
end of my bed
and she said she thought it was a lovely
thing and i don't know i think it's a
beautiful thing if some spirits stick
around
job probably deep down i don't believe
in ghosts but it kind of makes life fun
and i love getting goosebumps when
people tell me ghost stories it's a
lovely feeling
[Music]
all right well speaking of goosebumps
only one more
scorching hot sauce to go honestly i've
i really think you're you're a lovely
person but i'm so excited for this to be
over
[Laughter]
well good news sam it's almost over this
isn't
all right cheers sam cheers thank you so
much for having me
[Music]
all right sam smith here we are at the
encore of our spicy symphony with the
wings of death and only one more swan
song before we pull the curtain
you're raw you're honest and i love this
quote about redefining the global pop
star
i want to change the whole idea of when
i'm older
i want to be perfect i want to change
people's idea of what perfection is
with the fury of 10 scorching hot
chicken wings rushing through you right
now
i have a very lofty existential question
what is perfection to you and how do we
stop
expecting it from ourselves i
genuinely thought as a kid i was
addicted to
watching uh famous people i guess
addicted to watching uh
people with perfect lives and thinking
that there was a destination that i
could get to
where um everything was gonna be okay
and
you weren't gonna feel pain anymore but
i'm learning now as i'm getting older
that
you know to feel joy and to feel
good things in your life and to actually
feel happiness
you have to accept that happiness is an
emotion that's
that's that's fluid and fleeting too and
some days you'll be sad and sometimes
you'll be nervous and some days you'll
be anxious
and some days you'll be horny sometimes
you'll
have spicy food in your mouth
but yeah it's it's more for me it's
about the accepting
of all emotions you know that's that's
what i find exciting it's a metaphor for
life it's a metaphor for the wings of
death
sometimes you just have to go through
the pain but then you know what you find
at the end of all that
a finish line a place of peace a victory
at the top of the mountain
and look at you sam smith taking on
these scorching hot wings and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera possibly a camera be if you
set it up whatever you have going on
over there
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
i just want to say thank you these these
getting through this has just taught me
that i have so much courage
and uh and i can handle the heat i can
really handle the heat
so bring on the heat
thank you
but i'm never ever gonna have that one
again ever i will never put that in my
mouth
ever again if you see this right now do
not put this in your mouth
it's horrific
oh my god my nipples
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
video and i have very exciting news
the newest member of the last dab family
is finally here
say hello to apollo the last dab
apollo here's my 30 second review for
what it's worth
this is the hottest last dab sauce that
we've ever made
by a lot i'm actually not even sure if
that's a selling point
but it's just fair warning the last dab
apollo it has that deep
rich complex flavor profile that
smokinet is known for
deep heavy diesel pepper big
extreme heat you don't have to if you
don't want to but if you want to
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the last dab apollo
around here we call it the gold label